she will begin her term as Italy's Prime
Minister in challenging times Georgia
Maloney has promised to form a new
government quickly as pressure mounts
both at home and abroad
particularly at such a critical time in
our nation we reiterate that we are
ready
we want to move forward as quickly as
possible
the new government she says will bring
stability to the country as it tackles
inflation and soaring Energy prices
Maloney's conservative blog won the
Parliamentary majority in last month's
elections but her leadership is already
being questioned
leaked audio messages suggests former
prime minister and Ally Silvio
Berlusconi bragged about his friendship
with Vladimir Putin appearing to justify
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
Russian ministers settle more than one
occasion that we are already at war with
them why because we provide weapons and
financial help to Ukraine I personally
can't express my opinion because if
someone shares it with the media it may
cause a disaster
but I'm very very very worried I
reconnected with President Putin a
little oh well a lot he sent me 20
bottles of vodka and a really sweet
letter for my birthday I responded with
20 bottles of Lambrusco and a similarly
sweet letter I've been declared by him
the first of his five true friends
the revelations have led to tensions
within Maloney's Coalition fueling fears
of radical far-right policies within her
block
she's tried to calm skepticism
especially among European allies but
doubts linger so question for Europe
will be is Italy going to go wobbly will
Italy remain a staunch NATO Ally will
Italy continue the draghi policy of
supporting Ukraine against the Russian
invasion Maloney says yes her deputies
are wobbly
her party the brothers of Italy has Neil
fascist Roots is tough on immigration
and has openly criticized the European
Union supporters say Maloney's Coalition
can help Italy's struggling economy but
critics fear it's shifting Europe's
geopolitics further to the right
now millions of people across Italy and
Europe cautiously await to see how the
nation's first far-right Coalition since
the second world war will govern
Al Jazeera